Agent Hogan hadn’t seen what had grabbed
the commander, the sounds of blood-curdling
screams had made his eyes instinctively snap
shut. Hogan kept both eyes tightly closed,
nothing but darkness blotting out his vision
even as the desperate, gravelly-voiced yells of
the Commander filled his ears. Then, suddenly,
there was a scream, one that was abruptly cut
off. With a heavy thud, something dropped to the
ground, close enough to Agent Hogan’s feet that
he could feel the vibrations of it hitting the
floor through his boots. It was the Commander,
completely still… and silent.
Even though he’d been trained to
look danger in the eye, Agent Hogan still didn’t
open his eyes, not even for a split second. This
was the first time that anything like this had
ever happened, and in the panic and confusion,
his natural survival instincts had overridden the
SCP Foundation’s various rules and protocols in
his head. And right now, something was telling
him not to look. That something was shifting and
moving, just beyond Agent Hogan’s eyelids. He
could hear a shuffling as something much taller
than an average human lumbered around.
It had been wailing before, shrieking in
uncontrollable and inconsolable despair, but now
its cries had lowered to a soft, sobbing whimper.
When someone’s eyes are closed, they aren’t
completely cut off from the world around them.
Just being unable to see things doesn’t
entirely dull a person’s awareness. Most
people have a kind of sense, a spatial alert
that tells them what’s nearby even if they
can’t see it. And in this particular moment,
Agent Hogan’s was going haywire. The thing,
the thing beyond his closed eyes, was moving
towards him, so close that he could feel its warm,
rancid breath on his skin. Just knowing it was so
close, hearing it breathe and sob gently, sensing
it standing so close to him, it made the agent’s
already pounding heart rate start to climb.
He could feel beads of sweat crawling down
the side of his face as the creature leaned
in closer. It almost felt like it was
trying to goad him into opening his eyes.
“Go on, just take a peek,” came a nagging,
gnawing voice at the back of Hogan’s mind.
He couldn’t help it; it was a natural human
response to be curious. But as intriguing
of a sight as it might have been, the creature
was far more terrifying; Hogan had no idea what
horror he’d be faced with if he even opened
his eyes for a second. Little did he know,
forcing himself not to look – whether out of fear,
or pure survival instinct – had just saved the
agent’s life. He could sense the creature turn and
start to slink off, getting further away again as
it lumbered around a corner on its elongated legs.
Still, Agent Hogan waited a little longer before
opening up his eyes again… just to be safe.
It had all started around a month earlier,
when the SCP Foundation had discovered a potential
anomaly was being housed by a group known as the
Department of Abnormalities. You see, back then,
the SCP Foundation wasn’t quite the sprawling,
ginormous anomaly containment organization some
might be familiar with. It was far from being in
its infancy at this point in time either, but the
Foundation was only just beginning to expand its
collection of dangerous and unusual anomalies.
They had received word of an anomaly that was
being held in a facility in Stuttgart, Germany,
where Department of Abnormalities personnel had
gone to great lengths to secure it. However,
despite all the measures they put in place,
this creature was able to escape and didn’t leave
a single survivor in its wake after breaking free.
And so, being unfamiliar with this kind of
situation, the SCP Foundation had to decide
what the best course of action would be.
The Foundation dispatched a retrieval team,
codenamed Zulu-9 A, to the facility that
the creature had broken free from. From
the location in Stuttgart, Zulu-9 A was able to
track the anomaly's movements to an undisclosed
mountainous region. It was believed that this
area was either the creature’s natural habitat,
where it had initially been captured, or
that the mountain at least closely resembled
a place that the anomaly would recognize as
home. Flying in aboard a chopper, the Zulu-9
A team assumed they could simply approach the
creature, and calmly coerce it long enough for
them to capture and escort it back to base.
It turned out they were very, very wrong.
As their chopper landed nearby and the
retrieval team closed in on the creature,
the captain of Zulu-9 A turned to talk to a
Foundation doctor that had accompanied the unit.
That one serendipitous action might have saved
his life… because it meant he wasn’t looking at
the anomaly. A sudden, intense shriek rang out,
as the creature started crying, turning towards
the rest of the approached retrieval unit.
In a panic, they pulled their triggers,
weapons erupting into a hail of deafening
gunfire… but it had no effect. The creature
dashed towards them, shrugging off every
oncoming attack, completely unscathed. But
the Zulu-9 A team weren’t so well-defended…
By the time the captain turned back around,
the creature had already vanished, seemingly able
to move much faster than first anticipated. Maybe,
once they’d taken a look at it, the
retrieval team thought the creature’s long,
disproportioned limbs would make its movements
clumsy and cumbersome. Not that a single one
of them was left standing to verify that.
The captain was left alone and stunned,
he hadn’t seen what had happened to his
team, only the aftermath… and it wasn’t
a pretty sight. Before long, backup arrived
in the form of Zulu-9’s B team. With the help
of this secondary unit, the captain was able
to eventually capture the creature and remand
it into SCP Foundation containment. How? By
placing a bag over its head. His theory was,
if it couldn’t see the retrieval team, it
couldn’t attack them. And while this strategy
might have worked, he was only half-right.
Of course, the SCP Foundation’s mandate has always
been to contain and study the anomalies that it
encounters, and this was all the more prevalent
during these earlier days of the organization.
So, naturally, once the creature had seemingly
been captured and secured, a group of overzealous
and eager scientists were quick to step in so that
they could closely examine the anomaly. And for a
time, they were able to with little obstruction.
They could determine the basic details
about the creature’s physiology and have
that information logged in its very own file
on the SCP Foundation’s internal database. But
one scientist made a very fatal mistake during
those early tests and studies. Perhaps because
the Foundation already had the creature captured
and secure within the walls of its own facility,
they believed it posed no further threat
to personnel anymore. That it couldn’t
hurt to remove the bag and take a closer look…
The very instant the bag was removed, chaos broke
loose. It was as if someone had lit the fuse of a
firework, only for it to explode before they could
rush to a safe enough distance away. Not only were
the scientists studying the creature horrified
by the sight of its grotesque, wide-jawed face,
but they were all seconds away from meeting the
same grim and grizzly fate as the retrieval team
sent to capture it. Now, they had seen its face,
and the monster was loose within the Foundation.
At that particular point in time, the Foundation’s
early mistakes, this kind of thing was
unprecedented. It had never happened before,
not once – and nobody knew what to do. Most of the
anomalies they had encountered so far were benign.
Either harmless oddities, passive and non-hostile
creatures or artifacts with a few strange or
unexplained properties but with no real sentience
to speak of. But this was a ferocious abomination,
intent on causing harm to the Foundation’s own
staff. So, someone needed to act, and do it fast.
A handful of armed Foundation agents happened to
be on site at the time, security officers Hendrix,
Hogan and Stevens as well as Sutton, the surviving
captain from the Zulu-9 A retrieval team. The
second that the creature was seen and began
retaliating against those that had seen its face,
deafening alarms began to blare. That
was all the warning they would get;
there were no Special Containment Procedures
yet, no protocol or standard procedure for
something like this. The Foundation didn’t even
have a term for the situation that was going on,
although after today they would.
This was the SCP Foundation’s
first ever containment breach.
Given that he’d been involved in
retrieving the creature that was now on the loose,
Captain Sutton took the lead of the small group,
co-ordinating them as their de-facto commander.
“Don’t worry, we just need to get another bag over
its head and get it back into containment,” he
instructed as calmly and confidently as he could,
given the tense circumstances.
“This thing is highly aggressive,
but if you stay out of its sight, it won’t come
after you. Stay low, check your corners, and stay
frosty. We’ll split into twos and fan out, should
have more of a chance of catching him that way.”
Little did Sutton realize his misguided advice
would cost him, and others, their lives. Hendrix
and Stevens stumbled across the creature
first. Poking their heads around a corner,
they spotted the tall, wiry humanoid shape
passing along the corridor that ran parallel
to the one they were stood in. The two agents
saw the creature, but as far as they could tell,
it hadn’t seen them. But that didn’t matter.
Just as they both turned down the corner,
ready to ambush the anomaly, the towering,
spindly form of the creature suddenly appeared
behind them, screeching as it attacked.
Hearing the sounds of the others falling
prey to the monster, Captain Sutton and Agent
Hogan rushed towards the source of their fellow
agents' screams. The de-facto Commander of the
group rushed a few paces ahead, confident that
he knew how to get the upper hand against the
creature. Trailing behind him, Agent Hogan had
been swept up in the panic of the whole situation.
He had no idea what this creature was, only that
half of the retrieval team sent to capture it had
all died. Their weapons were useless against it,
which made the gun Hogan gripped in his trembling
fingers feel unreassuringly ineffective.
Sutton turned a corner down the corridor
ahead, and that had been when he locked
eyes with the creature. Seeing its face for
the first time; he hadn’t even caught a proper
glimpse of it when he’d managed to capture
it in the mountains. But now he had seen it,
and it knew. From around the corner, unable to
see Sutton or the monster, Agent Hogan let the
panic get the better of him, and closed his eyes.
An action that had unknowingly saved his life.
Once the monster had passed him by, and Agent
Hogan had dared to open up his eyes again, his
mind started racing. It had seen him, that much
he was certain of; even with his eyes closed, he
had sensed just how close to him the creature had
gotten to him. It had to have seen him, and yet he
was still alive. Sutton had said it would attack
anyone that it saw… unless Sutton had got it all
wrong. The creature was attacking anyone it looked
at; it was going after anyone who looked at it.
It was learning that key difference that
allowed Agent Hogan to gain the upper hand
on the creature. However, he quickly realized
that the number of people in the facility was
rapidly dwindling. The longer the anomaly was able
to roam free, the more Foundation personnel would
see its face, and fall victim to its rage. Agent
Hogan realized what he would have to do, sending
out a message to the SCP Foundation higher-ups
that this anomaly was only attacking anyone who
looked at it. Then, he sealed himself in the
chamber where the scientists had been examining
the creature. They’d filmed the examination;
all Hogan had to do was watch the part of the
footage where the bag was removed, and look
at the anomaly’s face. The monster took care
of the rest. Traveling at impossible speeds,
SCP-096 appeared in the room behind Agent Hogan.
Ever since, the SCP Foundation has poured
innumerable resources into ensuring they
have enough personnel who are specially trained
to deal with containment breaches. Some will even
tell you that it was this first incident that
led to the idea of Mobile Task Forces, teams
that the Foundation can deploy within moments
to respond to anomalies breaking out of their
containment. Of course, who really knows if that’s
really true? Maybe half of it actually happened,
and the rest was built off rumors and hearsay.
If you sign up to join one of the SCP Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces nowadays, then perhaps your
commanding officer will tell you this story during
your basic training. It could be they’re trying to
intimidate you, or just reemphasize how important
the role of the MTFs is within the Foundation.
One thing is for sure, though; anyone assigned
to guard SCP-096’s chamber knows to close their
eyes in the event of another containment breach.
Now go and check out “SCP-096 THE SHY GUY (SCP
ANIMATION)” and “SCP-096'S SAD END!” for more!